- [Kim] Civil society
is one of those terms
that you might hear in
a politician's speech.
Maybe in a line about the
importance of maintaining
a strong relationship between
the government and civil society.
But what does it actually mean?
A society that's civilized?
Or maybe the part of
society run by civilians
rather than government agents?
In fact civil society is
a little hard to define.
Let's start with what it's not.
It's not government or elected officials
who are acting in their official capacity
as representatives of the state or nation.
That is the political sphere.
It's also not businesses or corporations
who exist primarily to make a profit,
that's the economic sphere.
And lastly, it's not purely
private aspects of society,
such as family or home life.
Civil society exists in
between these three spheres
and includes all of the
non-governmental groups,
associations, and institutions
that civilians form and join.
If you and your friends decide to create
a neighborhood cleanup club,
picking up litter from the streets
and planting trees in the park,
congratulations, you've
just joined civil society.
Some other examples of
civil society include
religious organizations,
professional associations,
charitable groups, or interest groups.
Non-governmental organizations or NGOs
are some of the most notable
actors in civil society.
These include organizations
like Doctors Without Borders.
Some organizations overlap
a bit with other spheres.
Labor unions, for example,
are voluntary organizations
but they overlap with the economic sphere
by petitioning businesses for better wages
and working conditions.
NGOs that have a humanitarian mission,
like Amnesty International
may overlap with the political sphere,
since they petition governments to change
how they treat their citizens.
Some non-governmental actors
are harder to classify
like the news media.
Where does it fall in civil society?
It usually has some goal of making money
but it also helps inform citizens
about the workings of government
and helps hold politicians
accountable to the public.
So the media plays a central
role in civil society.
So what's important about civil society?
Well all of these organizations
help connect people to their communities
and many of them strive to improve society
by influencing these spheres.
Often they're in conflict with one another
but most importantly they show us
that there are many ways beyond voting
or running for office
to become involved in
issues that you care about.